hello and welcome to see your plane
Jimmy sroufe and I am will be shorter
okay okay we got to get the gruene felt
okay yeah probably probably playable how
bad can it be able to just capture okay
now c5 let us all that line I wonder can
I go can I go d 50 s that a bad decision
and clear what cannot clear to me can
also take for possible transposition to
the main line but ok i'm going to try
the 5 i'm not sure about it really might
be that my pawn is vulnerable hmm not
sure not sure about this at all yeah
Knight b6 is coming and it should be
through that c4 so I'm going to support
the center
yeah yeah he success the normal move and
attacking the center kicking was
absolutely nothing this is why I've
advanced wow wow very dynamic approach
but certainly interesting ok I can go
here I'd just attacking thats e5 pawn
you should be five there was Knight
takes e4 I think my don't think I don't
think that was ok maybe that was a bit
of an unlucky decision okay so taking
this do this time but otherwise there's
absolutely no point here to my plane so
where to put it I could go here actually
threatening d7 maybe even though all
this cost tons of time
Jerry I don't have much choice this is
have to take with the rook hmm ok ok ok
I think I'm going to take this Knight
takes e4 hmm f3 is a super super slo-mo
really don't like that ok I think the
thing is the special only three is this
is really ridiculously place I mean the
only purpose is to win this material so
I'm going to going to do it scrap here
he wants to play the root key for route
before and then Bishop c4 maybe okay I'm
not very happy about it but
and black is very very decent
compensation for the for the exchange I
mean ending is okay yeah it's only also
find
even trading wouldn't be so bad its
bishops are very strong
my night is pretty bad on e2 it really
has to be improved
now my next move is very likely going to
be rook to d1 ft-1 trying to trade one
rook now got a backbone structure h1b
three but a 8th h1c three but I couldn't
really do much to prevent it now taking
a long time I was thinking okay I think
he wants to trick me a rookie one like
then be five or move like that but I can
take cheek and player I can take and
play 21
ok
let's force this trade oh no Bishop f2
and that happens if you play those fancy
moves like Quincy to it's got jtf2 now
yeah of course it's easy it's a very
simple thing ah you're taking I'm very
bad and completely unnecessary the
position was still completely okay check
there was no need for this at all check
check time morning no it's a bad
position still Bishop c4 is coming it's
not easy to find a good place if for the
peace
draw a third term it's it is drawing can
I always have this ideas against f7 it
might might be something that I can try
check yeah probably it's not not making
any huge difference what is pretty slow
black resides it's pretty slow earth to
play a little bit quicker than I mean we
started we started this when he offered
the draw i was even down long time I
think whatever whatever blundering f2
was it was a pretty bad move and it's
always sharp those green fields maybe d5
is a bad decision I don't know I didn't
didn't know this particular this
particular line yeah if I visible I to
be honest I just I just did not
calculate this correctly I was thinking
he might can take but this is of course
complete rubbish so there should be
three is probably wrong I can just take
okay rook e8 then thing is I can go F
for here now so this is not so good I
mean the compensation is pretty enormous
that is getting yeah and I'm not happy
about all this but I thought I had to I
mean a move like f3 is just not working
md5 and I'm falling apart this is what i
was seeing something like this that
cannot work I mean I did not calculate
it but ok the engine gives this month
which I didn't see but it just looks
completely wrong playing every year
so I decided to snatch that material but
it's definitely not fun an hour after he
takes yeah it's not so good i play that
well and now I should of course not play
this fancy stuff Quincy to which is I
mean I saw book do you wanna hook you
one in a prime but it doesn't have to
check and just fold it down and here
black is just better I think you should
have avoided the Queen trento I mean
here this is also better for black but I
thought with Queen some and on it would
be even more awkward I've had this blue
i managed to trade this so that it is
probably am probably going to be a draw
but okay simply was far too slow in this
in this this ending okay well thanks for
watching